hey youtubers it's Charlie so there's
some surprise Deadpool taco what not
happening this morning so I wanted to do
a bonus video there's also some special
Superbowl stuff happening that I'll
explain at the end of the video really
there's just been a whole bunch of
Deadpool stuff in general happening so
the first big news yeah Deadpool is a
hardcore movie it is a hard art
definitely crazy if you're really young
person you're going to see it with your
mob you're still totally going to have
an awesome time but you're gonna have a
really fun awkward story to tell your
friends afterwards TJ Miller said that
there's going to be a director's cut
that will be even more hardcore which is
no surprise of course they're going to
lean into the art there's always stuff
that they have to cut out of movies for
time or just because it's way too crazy
but yeah the idea that when you see the
full directors kind of it that's gonna
be even more raw that's pretty heavy
duty
he also said there's a whole bunch of
stuff that they had to cut out because
it was too graphic so here's a taste of
that actually Fox is kind of maybe not
talked about some of the harsher stuff
because I think it got kind of faux
racist and then I I think there's a
really funny one but just look like a
trucker [ __ ] on your shoulders and then
shaped ears into it you know but it's
like somebody pulled your balls up
through your mouth and then wrapped them
around your head so bringing awesome but
Deadpool killed Twitter this morning
Brian Reynolds did a Q&A so I'm just
gonna play the montage here answered a
bunch of questions not all of them are
specifically about Deadpool but it's
actually pretty quick so here we go okay
how does it feel um imagine if you will
for a moment a bald eagle and a bald
eagle is spreading his majestic wings
over a warm Hawaiian breeze that's how
it feels I mean if I'm going to be
perfectly honest I kept a couple things
I kept two things from the the Deadpool
set I kept the the stuffed unicorn
wearing assless leather chaps that
Deadpool carries around in the movie and
I also kept the Deadpool suit because I
waited 10 years to do the film so I'm
keeping the [ __ ] suit okay when I was
a kid I went to I actually went to all
the r-rated movies my father father of
the year took me to all of them and so
the first one I ever saw is stand by me
Rob Reiner movie incredible film River
Phoenix
Connell corey feldman richard dreyfuss
amazing anyway that's that's when we're
checking out I didn't I didn't actually
do a ton of preparation for the film
Deadpool I um I felt like I was ready
the second I stepped out of my mother
I'd probably like to go back to this
morning
in the hotel lobby a nursing mother
caught me staring and I didn't know what
the appropriate facial expression was
for that so I just kept on staring and
staring and staring and then I just kind
of got locked into that like a time warp
and I probably use the time machine to
go back there and just make that not
happen what what do I love most about
the Deadpool character I loved I loved
everything about the Deadpool character
I've waited 11 years to bring this guy
to the screen and um I love that he's
meta I love that he's very very funny I
love these violent but he undercuts the
violence with with comedy and fun and
playing Deadpool is a dream come true so
there you are for your sincere answer I
won franchise for Deadpool to be in it's
a non comic would be Twilight right Team
Edward
Team Jacob team Deadpool team fun the
answer to that one is that TJ Miller is
a maniac and nothing gets done when TJ
Miller's around um honestly I'm
surprised we're all still alive um
probably not although it is fun but I
would at some point loved to see my
family again um thank you a big bye wolf
all three of them are doing just fine so
I appreciate your concern though
vodka or Spider Man it's a good question
how about um how about a vodka soaked
spider-man that's super weird that's the
that's the leaked title to my memoir I
am NOT gonna insult you you donkey
punching mustard squirt okay you never
you never feel like you just got this
you know you Deadpool is a very specific
tone and and an ultra specific type
character so I was very nervous and you
know the fans are the ones that got us
to where we are there
wouldn't have this movie if not for them
the leak test footage happened they
screamed and yelled overwhelmed the
studio and the studio was forced to
allow us to make not only Deadpool movie
but the Deadpool movie that that the
world needs so I could definitely
imagine doing something with spider-man
at some point rarely do they place the
Photoshop directly in the buttocks
generally it's a like around underneath
over your shading and stuff like that
but it never goes inside a Deadpool
loves Star Wars Deadpool's obsessed with
Star Wars Deadpool has Star Wars or may
or may not have Star Wars sheets at home
on his bed a couple of you guys have
pointed out funny commercials that he's
been doing so this is actually a Mexican
cookie commercial which might sound
weird but it's just meant to be a funny
ad for the movie to get people to go see
the movie that's airing in Mexico whoop
Gilligan a meet Raj Bowman Academy and
may cantock a mask a mahi-mahi stoy
no Disney ah maemunah
no Miyamoto's no Mia was told us
gavel Yahoo what is available and as you
can see here despite the fact that he
loves to make fun of Wolverine he and
you Jack been really great friends if
you ever hear about a feud in Hollywood
like two actors yelling at each other
it's totally fake there are very few
public arguments that actors and people
in Hollywood have that are actually
genuine usually things like that are
done to create publicity Kanye West is a
genius at generating publicity for
himself all he has to do is say
something completely idiotic on Twitter
and everybody goes crazy
so of course Ryan Reynolds making fun of
Wolverines totally tongue-in-cheek
I think everybody understands that in
wall-e was making the rounds TJ Miller
did say you know I would really like to
see Deadpool vs. Wolverine I don't know
that Fox would do that because Hugh
Jackman's kind of on his way out he
actually said one of the reasons why
he's leaving Wolverine like Robert
Downey jr. has said he's going to be
Iron Man for the rest of time Hugh
Jackman could totally do that exact same
thing he could be Wolverine till he
literally turns into old man Logan super
old white-haired Logan but the level of
fitness that he has to maintain is way
higher than Robert Downey jr. people
would riot in the street if there was a
movie that Wolverine appeared in where
he did not take his shirt off and pop
his claws streaming running around in
order to be what you would call
camera-ready first scene like that you
have to be crazy fit which is just
really hard to do every single year for
like ten years straight even Stephen
Amell on arrow who's way younger than
Hugh Jackman has crazy sick abs says
that whenever he has to do a shirtless
scene on arrow whenever they're filming
a shirtless scene they have to give him
a weeks notice so he can do extra
workouts to get his crazy eight pack so
Hugh Jackman's been doing that almost
every day continuously since he started
being Wolverine and it's just brutal
Robert Downey jr. on the other side of
that does not go shirtless in Avengers
movies when was the last time you saw
tony stark shirtless in a movie so it's
just a little bit easier for him to
continue playing the role he doesn't
have to be the crazy rip dude walking
around but don't completely count out
Deadpool vs. Wolverine they could still
totally do something like that I'm just
I'm not expecting it I think Deadpool
and cable would likely be the Deadpool
sequel
but hugh jackman did say that he just
got his script for the new bull Vereen
movie they're actually getting ready to
shoot it and I do think it's going to be
a version of old man Logan for the last
big thing Super Bowls coming up Deadpool
kills the Superbowl it's going to be so
much fun so the weird marketing the
Deadpool is going to be doing during
Super Bowl Sunday is a little bit
different from the other networks so
there's going to be like Captain America
civil war trailer stuff there's going to
be some x-men apocalypse trailer stuff
little more traditional
Deadpool on the other hand is going to
be running continuous ads on every
single major network I don't know what
that's going to look like but it's
probably gonna be some twisted funny
thing I'll totally make a video for it
but what I'm expecting is like a bunch
of different types of clips so I'll
probably end up combining all those into
one video but there will be some funny
stuff so I will do a Deadpool kills the
Superbowl video afterwards be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I'll probably even do a special giveaway
just because I feel like the Deadpool
people have been going like way above
and beyond the call of marketing their
movie like they made a joke about how
lego sets spoil movies Avengers style
Avengers lego sets completely spoiled a
bunch of scenes the same thing happened
with Star Wars
now Deadpool is just riffing on that oh
my god I can't believe you spoiled the
hot air balloon scene how awesome is it
that they did that in no I don't think
those are actual Lego sets I think they
just made the box art so crazy Super
Bowl stuff happening this Sunday even if
you don't watch the Super Bowl
don't worry because whatever ends up
happening I'll do videos for it so all
you have to do is look out for that
stuff well you guys wait for that you
can click here for all my Deadpool
videos just my Deadpool playlist and you
can click here for my legends of
tomorrow video from last night they
totally did Eyes Wide Shut Stanley
Cooper it goes so funny thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you